i get a call one night and it was real
it was i don't know
one or two o'clock in the morning i get
a call from a sheriff's department a
couple counties away
from their dispatch so we need your help
we get there on a traffic stop
and they have an unusual occupant in the
vehicle
and i said well what and they said well
it they said it might be a deer
i said okay so i grabbed a big dog dog
crate and
my daughter wanted to go she was still
up we were night owls
and so she goes with me and so i go we
travel there took about an hour to get
there
and i get there and there's all the cops
are all on the side of the road and
they got the guy out there and they're
doing the they're still doing a sobriety
test on him
where he was drunk and i get up to the
car and there's baby deer
in the front seat and what was they
doing just sitting there well the guy
had to pet deer i mean the guy's driving
around drunk with pet deer in his car oh
hell yeah in the front seat
and they i think actually they tried i
think they got him for wanting
endangerment maybe
with like a passenger for because it's
an occupant oh
danger in that animal i guess that's and
uh it it was tame
i mean it been bottle fed and so my we
get the deer out put up my truck
now you got pictures he's got pictures
of that they're
had it in my truck bottle feeding it on
the way home was it
in the front seat or back seat that was
in the front seat of the car
hell yeah they're right in the front
seat i never had a seat belt it could
have been a damn date dude honestly well
young but i mean he had like you talked
about the bling it had a big fancy
collar on it they had a collar a little
duck pretty dog collar on it and it
look it's hard to meet somebody man in
some areas you know
no judgment it is but what it found out
the guy had
just like i talked to you before he
found it on
a band and said it was orphan wow picked
it up you know
and kept it because he didn't think
mommy's around but we kept it for a week
or so my daughter
she bottle-fed it and then we took it to
rehabber and they
don't i didn't check by me they raised
they'll bottle feeding raisins let me
turn them loose
take them out in the wild hope you
enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one